so again what I'm trying to get at here  through this gentleman's wisdom is that  the creative class that culturally aware  creative class is at a massive advantage  for cutting through the noise because  you got other people out there saying  buy my coffee mug on the flip side  because I've so many creative  over-indexing creative friends a lot of  them are too romantic to have marketing  skills or weren't born with that you  know there's very few people that are  blessed to have both and can do it and  you know I tell a lot of my creative  friends I'm like you need to find a  business partner give somebody 10  there's so many people out there  marketing [ __ ] yeah go find one of those  people and let them market your great  stuff yeah and give up 10 to 50 percent  if it takes that much because at the end  of the day if you're trying to make it a  living it's a business and if you don't  know how to run a business or if you  don't know what to do oftentimes it  doesn't work out well